BACKER FORGES HAVE I EVER FOR
TESTING DALLY DOG EGGMAN LASER
GONZALEZ ROVE HURTS BERG WEST
SO- TADO JONES CAMCORDER LAYERED
LEYVA LIMONIUM MCGUIRE MELINDA'S
NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF BOTH
PAM FORTUNE TINO. RALPH RUBIO
SKINNER AMBERG WHITE HOUSE V.
WINNER WILL. MEMBERS OF THE
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER
THIS MORNING BY SENATOR LEYVA
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. BY SENATOR OCHO ABOUT.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS WE BEGIN WITH
THE WORDS OF THE POET AUDRE
LORDE. WHEN I DARE TO BE
POWERFUL TO USE MY STRENGTH IN
THE SERVICE OF MY VISION. THEN
IT BECOMES LESS AND LESS
IMPORTANT WHETHER I AM AFRAID.
RATIONS AND LOVING GOD AS WE
ENTER NEW MODES OF HUMAN
PRESENCE WHERE WOMEN ARE NOT
MERELY OBSERVERS. BUT WHERE EACH
CAN BE A PARTICIPANT IN THIS
MOMENT OF EVOLUTION. WE ARE
DETERMINED TO BE BOLD
PARTICIPANTS RATHER THAN TIMID
SAINTS IN WAITING. WE CHOOSE TO
EXERCISE THE AUTHORITY OF
HONESTY RATHER THAN THE
FEARFULLY DEFER TO POWER. WE
WISH TO INFLUENCE OTHERS FOR
JUSTICE RATHER THAN IMPRESS THEM
FOR GAME. AND BY YOUR GRACE WILL
BRING TREASURE OF JOY FRIENDSHIP
AND PEACE TO OUR WORLD WHEN WE
ALL USE OUR STRENGTH IN THE
SERVICE OF OUR VISION A MAN.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. I
REMEMBER THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. MEMBERS TODAY
WE HAVE SENATOR SENATORS BATES
BRADFORD DOURADO MEN AND STERN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME SENATORS.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED RED. MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION MEASURES REPORTED FROM
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WITH A RECOMMENDATION DO PASS
WILL BE GIVEN THEIR SECOND
READING UPON BEING REPORTED AND
ORDERED TO THIRD READING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MEASURES
REPORTED WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS DO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS WILL BE GIVEN THEIR
SECOND READING AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED AND RETURNED TO SECOND
READING UPON BEING REPORTED.
SENATORS THIS IS THE TIME TO
REMOVE IT MEASURES FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE IS THERE ANYBODY
WHO UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
SOMETHING FROM THE INACTIVE.
LOOKING LOOKING LOOKING. SEEING
NONE. WE'RE MOVING ON TO
INTRODUCTIONS AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS BILLS WILL BE DEEP RED
. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. RING ON THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT SENATOR LETTERED.
IDM NUMBER TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OF FINAL ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY TWO IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF JULIA MONTGOMERY
AS GENERAL COUNSEL TO
AGRICULTURE LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD SHE HAS SERVED IN THIS
POSITION SINCE SHE WAS
ORIGINALLY APPOINTED AND
CONFIRMED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
PRIOR TO HER ORIGINAL
APPOINTMENT SHE SERVED AS
ASSISTANT CHIEF COUNSEL OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON JANUARY
TWELFTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THING THEN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA FIVE ADKINS. FIVE
BACKER FIVE FOUR JUST NO COME BY
OTHER FIVE PROTESTING FIVE DALLY
DOT FIVE EGGMAN. FIVE LASER FIVE
ALL AS I GROW. HERTZBERG I WAS
SO. HI HER TADO. JONES NO CAN
WATER I LAYERED I LABOR HI THE
MON FIVE WIRE HI MELINDA'S.
NEWMAN BY NIELSEN NO A TROUBLED
NO PAM HI FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH. FIVE RUBIO. HI SKINNER. HI
NUMBER ALL RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI
FIVE WINNER I WILL. NOW. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLY
GROWTH. HER TADO MELINDA'S. FIVE
TWENTY SIX KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE- THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
THREE SENATOR LOTT LAYERED. HOLD
ON JUST A SECOND I THINK WE NEED
TO GET THE MICROPHONE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THE FINAL ITEM
TWENTY THREE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF DOCTOR SUSAN ALREADY LEFT.
FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. BUT SHE IS NOT
THOMAS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
TRUSTEE AND ALSO SERVES AS
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION. SHE
WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JANUARY TWELFTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR PENN THANK YOU
MADAM PRESENCE AT ARCHER'S EYE
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
CONFIRMATION OF- DOCTOR SUSAN
HER READY- WHO IS- MENTIONED- MY
GOOD FRIEND IS ACTUALLY V. ON
THE SCHOOL BOARD FOR THREE
SCHOOL BOARD MY CHILDREN
ACTUALLY- THE SCHOOL DISTRICT MY
CHILDREN ATTEND- THAT SHE'S BEEN
A LONGSTANDING SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER THERE. AS WELL AS OF
COURSE BEING PRESENT A CSPA
BASHA ALSO POINT OUT HE'S ALSO
AN EDUCATIONAL EXPERT PREVIEW
SERVES A FACULTY MEMBER. OVER
AT- CSU SECOND TELL IN FACT THAT
WAS THE PART. HEY AT FIRST. HI
HUNDRED CONFIRMATION YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. ALAN I ARCHULETA I. ATKINS
FIVE BECKER HI FOR JUST. BY ADAM
I PROTECTING FIVE DALLY DOT BY
ADMIN FIVE LASER FIVE DOLLARS
FIVE GROVE. HURTS BURKE FIVE
WESA. HI HER TADO. JONES
CAMCORDER I LAYERED I LABOR HI
THE MON FIVE WIRE HI MELINDA'S.
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. BUT SHOW BOTH
PAM HI FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I
REVIEW FIVE SKINNER. HI NUMBER
HI CASKEY I WINNER I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOR JUST. DALLY GROVE. HER TADO
. JONES MELINDA'S. NIELSEN A
TRIO OF BOTH. WELL. PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. BORJAS VALLEY
. GROVE TADO. JONES MELENDEZ
NIELSEN A TRAIL OF BOTH. WELL
FIVE TWENTY SIX NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO
SENATE THIRD READING GOING TO
TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
SENATOR SKINNER IS READY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RUN SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR SKINNER RELATIVE TO
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CENTER SKINNER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. JANUARY TWENTY SECOND
TO SATURDAY IS THE FORTY NINTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE SUPREME
COURT'S RULING IN ROE VERSUS
WADE THAT RULING DEFINE OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO PRIVACY
AS A RIGHT THAT INCLUDES THE
RIGHT TO ABORTION. BEFORE ROE
VERSUS WADE. ABOUT ONE POINT TWO
MILLION AMERICANS RESORTED TO AN
ILLEGAL ABORTION EVERY YEAR. I
WAS FORTUNATE TO BEGIN MY
REPRODUCTIVE YEARS NEAR THE TIME
OF THE ROE V. WADE DECISION AS A
RESULT I HAD ACCESS TO ALL OF
THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES I NEEDED I DID NOT HAVE
TO FACE THE SHAME THE COST OF
THE POTENTIALLY LETHAL
CONSEQUENCES OF HAVING AN
ILLEGAL ABORTION. BEFORE ROE V.
WADE WOMEN RISKED THEIR LIVES.
ILLEGAL ABORTIONS COST UP TO
FIVE THOUSAND DEATHS ANNUALLY.
AND MANY OTHER HEALTH
COMPLICATIONS. LIKE MANY MANY
PEOPLE. I GOT PREGNANT
UNINTENTIONALLY A PREGNANCY I
HAD NOT PLANNED FOR. I CAN
DESCRIBE THE CIRCUMSTANCES BUT
IN MANY RESPECTS THERE IN
MATERIAL WHETHER IT WAS FAILED
BIRTH CONTROL SEX I DIDN'T
CHOOSE. WRONG TIME IN MY LIFE OR
A RELATIONSHIP I DIDN'T INTEND
TO HAVE. REGARDLESS OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THAT
UNINTENTIONAL PREGNANCY.
FORTUNATELY THEY WERE NOT LEGAL
OR OTHER OBSTACLES BEFORE ME.
INSTEAD I WAS ABLE TO WEIGH MY
SITUATION AND MAKE THE VERY
PERSONAL DECISION TO HAVE AN
ABORTION. AN ABORTION I HAD. AND
I DO NOT REGRET. IT WAS WHAT I
NEEDED AT THE TIME AND WAS ABLE
TO I WAS ABLE TO GET THAT CARE
AT A SAFE HEALTH CARE SETTING.
TODAY HOWEVER AN INCREASINGLY
OVER THE LAST DECADE. WE ARE AND
HAVE BEEN EXPERIENCING AN
ONGOING RELENTLESS ATTACK. ON
ABORTION ACROSS THE NATION. JUST
A FEW MONTHS AGO TEXAS PASSED SB
EIGHT. BY BANNING ABORTIONS
AFTER SIX WEEKS THE TIME PERIOD
THAT MOST DON'T EVEN REALIZE YET
THEY ARE PREGNANT. S. B. EIGHT
IN FACT UNDERMINES ROVI WAY AND
JUSTICES ON THE SUPREME COURT
WHO HAVE PUBLICLY EXPRESSED
THEIR OPPOSITION TO ABORTION
HAVE FOR NOW LET S. B. EIGHT
STAND. MISSISSIPPI FLORIDA AND
DOZENS OF OTHER STATES ARE
POISED TO FOLLOW SUIT. IF THOSE
SAME JUSTICES VOTE TO OVERTURN
ROE VERSUS WADE OR CONTINUE TO
ALLOW BANDS LIKE ESP EIGHT TO
REMAIN. ON OVER HALF THE STATES
IN THE US WILL LOSE ACCESS TO
ABORTION CARE WHICH COULD IMPACT
OVER THIRTY SIX MILLION PEOPLE
WHO COULD BECOME PREGNANT. S. R.
SIXTY THREE HONORS THE FORTY
NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF ROE VERSUS
WADE AND REAFFIRMS CALIFORNIA'S
OUR STATE'S LEADERSHIP ROLE AS A
NATIONAL LEADER FOR REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM. I URGE YOU TO VOTE ON
SR SIXTY THREE YES BUT- MADAM
PRO TEM ADKINS.
THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT ALEX I RISE ALSO IN
SUPPORT AND IS A PROUD CO AUTHOR
OF SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY THREE
A RESOLUTION COMMEMORATING A
CRITICALLY DEFINING MOMENT IN
THE HISTORY OF REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS IN THIS COUNTRY THE
SUPREME COURT'S RULING ON JANE
ROE L. VERSUS HENRY WADE. THE
LANDMARK DECISION DETERMINED
THAT A PREGNANT PERSON'S RIGHT
TO CHOOSE TO HAVE A SAFE AND
LEGAL ABORTION IS A LIBERTY AS
STATED BY THE AUTHOR. BY THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT OF THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES. YET DESPITE THIS CLEAR
RULING THAT A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE IS PROTECTED BY HER
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO PRIVACY
NOT A DAY HAS GONE BY IN THE
LAST FORTY NINE YEARS. WHEN
ABORTION RIGHTS HAVE NOT BEEN
UNDER THREAT. NO MORE SO THAN
TODAY. AS WE SPEAK OTHER STATES
ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH POLICIES
TO RESTRICT ABORTION ACCESS AND
ESTABLISH UNITIVE LEGAL
STRUCTURES TO INTIMIDATE. AND
DISENFRANCHISE PREGNANT PEOPLE
WHO CHOOSE ABORTION. THE THREAT
OF THESE POLICIES IS ONLY
MAGNIFIED WHEN WE CONSIDER THE
RECENT COURT RULINGS AS ALSO
INDICATED AT EVERY LEVEL AND THE
DELIBERATIONS OCCURRING AT OUR
SUPREME COURT. WE'VE BEEN HERE
BEFORE AND WE KNOW WHERE IT
LEADS. WE'VE COME MUCH TOO FAR
TO LOSE GROUND ON OUR
INDISPENSABLE RIGHT TO MAKE
CHOICES ABOUT OUR OWN BODIES
FREE OF EXCESSIVE GOVERNMENT
RESTRICTION. TODAY AS WE LOOK
BACK AND REFLECT ON ROE VERSUS
WADE I URGE YOU TO REMEMBER THE
REALITIES OF A WORLD WITHOUT
ABORTION RIGHTS. WE MUST NOT
FORGET THE COUNTLESS WOMEN WHO
RISK AND TOO OFTEN LOST THEIR
VERY LIVES IN ORDER TO END
UNWANTED PREGNANCIES. LET ME END
UP MAKING ONE THING CLEAR
CALIFORNIA HAS DOES AND WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT WOMEN. AND
OUR FAMILIES AT EVERY TURN NOT
JUST ON THE ISSUE OF ABORTION.
FOR MANDATING MEDICAL COVERAGE
FOR LIFE SAVING BREAST CANCER
SCREENINGTO PROVIDING FUNDING
TO SUPPORT BLACK INFANT HEALTH
IN THE BUDGET. WE'LL CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE POLICIES PROVIDE
RESOURCES AND SERVICES. TO
INDIVIDUAL OR FAMILY OUR KIDS OF
ALL KINDS AT ALL STAGES. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING SR SIXTY
THREE. CENTER DRAWS A. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AS CHAIR OF THE
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
RESOLUTION SIXTY THREE
CALIFORNIA'S LONG STOOD AS THE
MODEL FOR RECOGNIZING AND
FORTIFYING THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
THE RIGHT TO AN ABORTION HAS
BEEN LEGAL FOR NEARLY FIFTY
YEARS UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY
WOMEN FACE TOO MANY BARRIERS
TRYING TO ACCESS A SAFE MEDICAL
PROCEDURE. FOR LATINOS THESE
BARRIERS ARE LAYER IMMIGRANT
WOMEN HAVE DIFFICULTY FINDING
CULTURALLY COMPETENT CARE THEY
FEAR AND OFTEN MISTRUST
GOVERNMENT PROVIDED CARE. BLACK
AND WE'RE- THE NEXT WHICH ARE
OFTEN AWAY AND THE PROCEDURES
ARE COSTLY ABOUT 60% OF LOW
INCOME NON CITIZEN IMMIGRANT
WOMEN OF REPRODUCTIVE AGE LACK
HEALTH INSURANCE WHICH IS MORE
THAN TWICE THE PROPORTION OF LOW
INCOME US BORN WOMEN WE MUST
ENSURE THAT REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOMS ARE ACCESSIBLE TO EVERY
CALIFORNIAN. FINANCIAL BARRIERS
STILL REMAIN THE NUMBER ONE
REASON THAT SO MANY ARE UNABLE
TO GET TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE THE
WAY TO WIN AN HONOR ROLL VERSUS
WADE IS FOR REPRODUCTIVE CARE
AND TO FIGHT FOR HEALTHCARE
EQUALITY AND TO EXPAND ACCESS
THANK YOU MANAGER. SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE
RESOLUTION SIXTY THREE WHICH
COMMEMORATES THE FORTY NINTH
ANNIVERSARY OF ROE VERSUS WADE
AND II M. AS ASTONISHED AS ALL
OF YOU TO BE HERE IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO ALMOST FIVE DECADES
LATER AND TO SAY THAT NOW MORE
THAN EVER THIS LANDMARK UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT DECISION IS
OF ABSOLUTE CRITICAL IMPORTANCE.
ROVI WAY TO ENSURES AMERICANS A
TANAMI OVER THEIR OWN BODIES
LET'S FACE IT WOMEN AS THESE
REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS HAVE BASS
EFFECTS ON THEIR ENTIRE LIVES IF
AND WHEN A PERSON CHOOSES TO
INCORPORATE A FAMILY INTO THEIR
LIFE SHOULD ALWAYS BE THEIR
DECISION AND THEIR DECISION
ALONE. THE RIGHT TO OBTAIN LEGAL
ABORTIONS AND SAFE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SHOULD NOT BE FOR A. FOR STATE. THREE CAN'T SHOULD
AN ALREADY MEMBERS IF ROE V.
WADE IS EVER OVERTURNED IF
ABORTIONS BECOME ILLEGAL BUT
PEOPLE REALLY DON'T UNDERSTAND
IS THAT PEOPLE WILL NOT STOP
HAVING OF ABORTIONS MORE WOMEN
WILL JUST. WHEN WE DECIDE THAT
WOMEN ACTUALLY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS I'M
SURE THAT MANY HEREON THIS
FLOOR WOODEN AND ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD WOULDN'T LIKE US MAKING
LAWS THAT TOLD THEM WHAT THEY
COULD DO WITH THEIR **** SO I
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION AND I
SUPPORT A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO A
SAFE. AND LEGAL ABORTION THANK
YOU. ENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
ALSO BRYSON STRONG SUPPORT A
SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY THREE TO
COMMEMORATE THE FORTY NINTH
ANNIVERSARY. OF THE LANDMARK
SUPREME COURT DECISION ROE
VERSUS WADE I WANT TO ADD MY
VOICE AND I CALLED ALL THE
WONDERFUL COMMENTS ALREADY MADE
HERE BY MY COLLEAGUES TODAY. ROE
VERSUS WADE HAS BEEN THE
CORNERSTONE. AND THE PROGRESS OF
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS IN
THIS COUNTRY. FOR ALMOST HALF A
CENTURY ALMOST FIFTY YEARS WOMEN
ACROSS THIS NATION. I HAVE HAD
ASSURANCES THAT THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO HAVE
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM OVER THEIR
BODIES EXIST. AS A NATION WE ARE
STILL FAR AWAY FROM TRUE GENDER
EQUALITY. YET FOR FORTY NINE
YEARS ROE VERSUS WADE HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN GETTING WOMEN
CLOSER TO THAT GOAL AND AS WE
KNOW TODAY IT'S BEING CHALLENGED
. ROE VERSUS WADE IS SO
IMPORTANT IN ALLOWING WOMEN TO
PLAN THEIR OWN LIVES HAVE BETTER
CONTROL. OVER PURSUING
PROFESSIONAL CAREERS AND ALIGN
WOMEN TO BE GREATER CONTRIBUTORS
TO THIS COUNTRY AND IN AND OUT
ALLOWING WOMEN TO BETTER PLAN
THEIR FAMILIES. AND SUPPORTING
CENTER RESERVATION SYSTEM SIXTY
THREE WE REQUEST THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO MAINTAIN THE
PROGRESS WE HAVE MADE FOR WOMEN.
LET US NOT GO BACK. I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. SENATOR
PENN. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT THIS R. SIXTY THREE.
THIS IS A PHYSICIAN AND ALSO
CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND THE-
MARKING THIS FORTY NINTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE SUPREME
COURT'S DECISION ON ROE VERSUS
WADE. EVERY PERSON HAS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO MAKE THEIR
OWN REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS AND
THERE ARE MANY REASONS WHY
SOMEONE MAY CHOOSE TO DO SO. AND
CERTAINLY- AS A PHYSICIAN I KNOW
THAT THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT
REASONS- WHICH ONE THEY CHOOSE
TO DO SO SOME OF WHICH MAY
ACTUALLY INVOLVE RISK TO HER OWN
LIFE- READ. AS WELL BUT ALSO I
MAKE NOTE THAT IS MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM BERKLEY SAID- THE REASON
ISN'T THAT. REASON THIS IS THE
WOMAN'S. AND SHOULD NOT
NECESSARILY- BE QUESTIONED IN
THAT REGARD. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WOMEN HAVE ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH INCLUDING
ABORTIONS AND HEALTHCARE. IN
FACT IF ROVERS WILL PERSUADE IS
OVERTURNED MORE THAN EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND ASIAN WOMEN IN
THIS COUNTRY WHO ARE OF
REPRODUCTIVE AGE OR RISK LOSING
ACCESS. THE CRITICAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SERVICES THAT COULD
SAVE THEIR LIVES. THAT IS WHY
OVER 70% OF ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS SUPPORT ROE VERSUS
WADE. THE PEOPLE OF AMERICA
AMERICANS HAVE SAID STRONGLY-
NUMEROUS POLLS THAT THIS IS A
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT RIGHT TO
THEM. CERTAINLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER IN
HEALTHCARE WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ENSURE EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF
GENDER HAS ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
THEY NEED. BUT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT OUR COUNTRY. UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA CONTINUE TO PROTECT
THIS RIGHT THE SUPREME COURT HAS
DECLARED FOR NOW OVER FORTY NINE
YEARS. SO I STRICTLY ASKED THAT.
WE VOTE FOR YOU TO VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS R. SIXTY THREE
THANK YOU. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. FURTHER DISCUSSION.
EIGHT SAYING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
SCANNER YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF S. R.
SIXTY THREE AND I WANT TO
REITERATE SOME OF THE COMMENTS
BY THE PRO TEM UM. I KNOW THAT.
WE AS THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
BEEN COMMITTED. FOR MANY MANY
YEARS TO PROVIDE ALL THE SUPPORT
WE CAN HEALTH CARE SUPPORTS.
CHILD CARE FAMILY SUPPORTS. UP
REMOVING BARRIERS TO ECONOMIC
OBSTACLES- EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCE ANOTHER
CIRCUMSTANCE ABLE TO THRIVE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA NOW WE'VE NOT YET
FULLY ACHIEVE THAT. BUT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT AND THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS BEEN
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT. A
WOMAN WHETHER SHE IS A SINGLE
MOTHER OR IN A- PRINT PARTNERED
FAMILY THAT SHE HAS THE ABILITY
TO RAISE HER CHILDREN WITH
SUPPORT. HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT AS
MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE
STATED I STATED THAT PEOPLE
STILL HAVE THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
NOT TO PURSUE A PREGNANCY AND
THAT IS WHAT ROE VERSUS WADE
ALLOWED. AND AS WE FACE THIS
ONSLAUGHT OF ATTACK ON THE OUR
ABILITY TO SEEK THE REPRODUCTIVE
CARE THAT WE NEED. A FREEDOM
THAT THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
SUPPORT I KNOW ALL THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT JUST STAND
BY. I AM PROUD THAT WE ARE A
STATE COMMITTED TO PROTECTING
AND PROVIDING ACCESS TO ABORTION
AND ALL REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES
NOT ONLY FOR CALIFORNIANS BUT
ALSO FOR THOSE WHO MAY SEEK
REFUGE HERE. AND WE'RE
DETERMINED WE'LL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT FOR EVERY PERSON'S RIGHT
TO BODILY AUTONOMY TO EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE TO FREEDOM
TO CHOOSE FOR WHAT'S BEST FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR HEALTH. AND
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO
READ DESCRIBED THE QUALITY FOR
THE REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS OF ALL
GENDERS WHETHER THEY LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA OR ANOTHER STATE WE
WILL NOT GIVE UP THIS FIGHT AND
I URGE A YES VOTE ON SR SIXTY
THREE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS FIVE BECKER
HI FORGES. CABRERA HI PROTESTING
HI DOLLY. DOT FIVE A GUNMAN I.
LASER EYE CONSOLIDATES I GROW.
NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES NO ONE CAN LONGER I
LAYERED BY LABOR. FIVE THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN. BUT BOTH NO PAM ARCADE
PORTS AND TINA I BROUGHT I RUBIO
. HI SKINNER HI AMBER HI WHAT
KIND OF SKI I WINNER I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS DALLY. HER TADO.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN NO WELL. FIVE
TWENTY SIX KNOWS FOR THE
RESOLUTION IS APPROVED. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO MANY.
ANNOUNCEMENTS MAYBE
ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR PORTENT
TINA. TEN O'CLOCK THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
CONVENE AT TEN O'CLOCK IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. VERY GOOD.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR
. WHEN PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH- COLLEAGUES ARE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AT TWO PM THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE. WE WLL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM.